le confie à marioupol vient de franchir
un nouveau palier c'est ce que viennent
d'annoncer les autorités ukrainiennes
pour la première fois les forces russes
auraient attaqué lusine daz obstacles
avec des chars et blindés des soldats
auraient également tenté de débarquer à
l'aide de bateaux et de l'infanterie
jusqu'à présent l'armée russe bombardait
lusine par avion et depuis la mer un
changement de stratégie qui
s'expliquerait par le comportement du
régime en azote la milice nationaliste
qui forment le gros des troupes
l'ukrainienne toujours retranchés à
l'intérieur selon le ministère russe de
la défense elle aurait profité du cessez
le feu pour sortir des sous-sols de la
syrie et se positionner autour du
bâtiment la milice a diffusé des vidéos
montrant des victimes de bombardements
dans la nuit
ses deux filles étaient dans la cuisine
il n'y avait pas de soldats il n'y avait
pas de mandres d'azov on se préparait
pour l'évacuation
le cauchemar se poursuit donc pour
environ 200 civils toujours abrité dans
les sous sols du complexe métallurgique
selon le maire de mario paul ce week-end
pour la première fois en deux mois de
siège et de bombardements
une centaine de civils ont pu être
évacués une partie d'entre eux sont
arrivés dans la ville proche de zappos
ridge à se contrôler l'ukrainien malgré
escalade de la violence le président
ukrainien escarres poursuivre
l'évacuation
sans aucun doute nous continuerons à
faire tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir
pour faire sortir tous nos concitoyens
de marioupol d'ostal c'est difficile
mais nous avons besoin de tout le monde
nous tous ceux qui restent là-bas civils
et militaires
l'onu souhaite toujours organiser
d'autres évacuations humanitaires d'une
partie de la population de marioupol
notamment les personnes ayant besoin de
soins médicaux